how do we remove ourselves from the
clown show you know what we have to do
we have to put people in office who are
clear and competent and have a sense of
what the actual mission is uh I don't
know if you've heard of this guy Ron
DeSantis here in Florida check this out
what I see around the country with
Republicans is they started to develop a
culture of losing and it's almost like
this is something we saw it in Wisconsin
with this Supreme Court race we saw with
a very disappointing midterm elections
in Florida we have a culture of winning
we have a culture of execution and we
have a culture of delivering results and
you need to be able to win it's not easy
when you stand for the right things in
this day and age man you are going to
have a lot of blowback leadership isn't
cost free my view is that I may have
earned 50 of the vote but that entitled
me to wield 100 of the executive power
and I intended to use that to advance a
bold agenda I intended to use that to
fulfill my campaign promises and to do
that I resolved at the beginning of my
term no polls I am not going to just put
my finger in the wind and try to chase
poll results I'm going to set the rudder
to True North uh and I'm going to do
that and I know there's all kinds of
stuff that happens on The Daily News
cycle I'm not going to let that divert
me on our off of course a poll uh can
tell you a snapshot in time but it does
not tell you what the results would be
if a leader sets out a vision executes
on that vision and then delivers results
leaders are not captive to polls leaders
get in front of the polls and then shape
public opinion and that's what we said
we would do execution and delivering
results what do I keep saying we want
Clarity competency and communication
that's exactly what we're doing he's
executing on the things he said he would
do one at a time if you're watching this
right now and even for the for the Trump
people that are a little more annoyed at
me at the moment because I've been a
little more critical of trump and again
I might vote for Trump I basically like
Trump I just don't like the attacks but
okay
tell me something if you're a rapid
lefty or you're watching the show or
you're a trump person watching the show
tell me something that the scientists
set out to do that he has not done
he has gone ahead and done all of it and
by doing it and by not caring about the
polls just going ahead and doing what
was right as you know he went from under
40 000 vote victory in 2018 to over 1.6
million victory
in 2022 that's big that is big so if you
pick the fights properly you will also
and this is the other interesting part
you all know this there's a reason why
you're Democrat or lefty or liberal
friends are so crazed they're so crazed
because they're not connected to reality
if you don't understand the biological
differences between a boy and a girl if
you don't understand that this new
leftist racism is just a repurposed
version of Old School racism so many of
the things if you don't understand why
the Democrats run around pretending they
care about poor people but it's all of
the cities that Democrats run that poor
people have at the worst and
homelessness is the worst and druggies
and all those things they're so
disconnected from reality but what they
do but what we're nice but we give other
people's money to things we're very nice
so these people become endlessly
hysterical
[Music]